2026년 4월 30일 목요일 미국 증시 유약입니다.
금일 미국 증시는 상승 마감했습니다.
미국 경제의 견주한 흐름을 보여주는 경제 지표와
긍정적인 기업 실적이 투자들의 낙관론에 불을 지폈습니다.
유가 하락이 투자 심리를 개선하며 채권 강세를 이끌었고
N화는 일본 당국의 외환시장 개입 간성이 제기되며 반등했습니다.
장마 가무 애플은 아이폰과 맥수요 호조에 힘입어
시장 예상치 루토는 매출을 발표했습니다.
1분기 실적 발표가 집중된 이번 주
투자들은 수요 장마 가무 공개된 하이퍼 스케일러의 실적을 주시했습니다.
구글은 클라우드 부분에서 사상 최대 분기 실적을 달성하며 10% 급등했고
아마존은 0.8% 상승했습니다.
반면 메타와 마이크로소프트는 각각 8.6%, 3.9% 하락했습니다.
메타는 시장의 예상치를 상해하는 자본 지출 계획이 부담으로 작용한 데다
사용자 증가세 마감과
마자 기대에 못 미치며 하방 압력을 받았습니다.
마이크로소프트 역시 높은 메모리 비용 탓에
자본 지출이 1,900억 달러에 달할 것이로 밝히면서
주가가 약세를 보였습니다.
경제지표 측면에서는 미국 1분기 GDP가 연일 0.2% 성장했습니다.
이는 직전분기 0.5%다는 개선된 수치이지만
시장 예상치인 2.2%에는 미치지 못했습니다.
그러나 신규 실업상 청구 건수가 1969년 이후 최저치로 떨어지며
고용시장의 경과함을 재확인했습니다.
다만 연준이 선호하는 인플레이션 지표인
개인소비지출 물가지수가 지난달 0.7% 상승하며
2022년 이후 가장 큰 폭으로 오른 점은 부담 요인으로 남았습니다.
이는 단기 금리 인하에 대한 시장의 기대를 약화시키는 요인으로 작용하고 있습니다.
노슬라이트의 크리스트 자카랠리는
경제가 지속적으로 성장하고 기업들이 실적을 늘릴 수 있다면
에너지 가격 상승과 인플레이션 우려 속에서
주가는 상승할 수 있다.
다만 전쟁이 장기화될수록 시장의 불안감이 요동치며
증시가 조정을 받을 가능성도 있다.
이토로의 브랫케넬은
기업 실적이 시장 분위기를 주도하며
증시가 1분기 저점에서 순조롭게 반등했지만
에너지 가격이 계속 높은 수준을 유지할 경우
이러한 상승세가 지속될 수 있을지가 관건이다.
머피 앤 실베스트의 폴 롤테는
다수의 경제 지표가 투자들의 불안을 잠재워하고
무엇보다 다양한 기업들이 꽤 훌륭한 실적을 내고 있고
우리는 오늘 그 흥풍이 시장 전반으로 확산되는 것을
목격하고 있다. 라고 전하였습니다.
2026년 5월 1일 금요일 주요 일정 살펴보겠습니다.
경제 지표는 22시 45분 미국 4월 S&P 글로벌 제조 PMI
23시 미국 4월 ISM 제조 PMI
02시 미국 베이커 유즈 총회장의 제조 PMI
총 시축 이수가 예정되어 있습니다.